the man accused of killing a
two-year-old boy and hiding his body was
back in court today
metro police say terrell rhodes did
confess to the crime
as bianca holman explains prosecutors
will soon decide whether or not to
pursue the death penalty
[Applause]
terrell rhodes appeared in court with
his lawyer after being in quarantine for
the past two weeks
you wished
the 27 year old is accused of killing
his girlfriend taylor nicholson's child
amari nicholson amari disappeared in the
care of rhodes on may 5th
at the emerald suites on paradise and
twain the community searched for the boy
for almost a week
rhodes confessed to killing the toddler
after the child wet himself
he's charged with murder along with
several other charges rhodes waived his
right for a speedy trial to allow his
lawyers more time
i understand that we don't have at least
a report that's not been informed
about whether or not you intend to take
this to the death
it will certainly committee presented to
the committee
we'll have an answer we have 30 days
from the filing of the indictment which
was last friday so
he'll get an answer for the court rhodes
will remain in jail without bail
rose will appear in front of a judge
again on june 11. reporting from the rjc
bianca coleman
8 news now